Fire Emblem fates is the latest in the
blockbuster tactics series and it's
finally coming to the US on februari
19th hopefully you've chosen between the
conquest and birthright versions of the
game or splurged on the special edition
if not you have even more options for
playing the game now conquest and
birthright are two sides of the same
story but Fire Emblem fates revelation
is another side all together this $20
DLC drops in March and it tells the tale
of your character refusing both the
conquest and birthright baths Nintendo
is also releasing for map packs the
first of which will launch the same day
as the main game plus you can always buy
the special edition for 80 bucks which
packs in all three of the paths an art
book and a 3ds XL pouch speaking of 3d
esas Fire Emblem fates is also getting
its own new 3ds XL model which releases
the same day as the game it doesn't
include the game but it does sports some
lovely art inspired by it it'll cost you
two hundred dollars there's definitely
no shortage of Fire Emblem material to
dig through next month and we'll be
covering all of it to keep up with all
the news and reviews keep your target on
gamespot